i hope it's okay that i mentioned the
goonies because i here's the thing it's
probably yours since you've been gone
that's the song every it's the only song
people think i've done in my career i
feel like sometimes and and and i'm like
cool there's other songs and i know
there's other movies there's a plethora
of many movies that you're in that
you're amazing but yeah this was your
first movie this is the movie that only
means something to you no
no no it's just i think of that coming
of age like whenever i was a kid like
first of all i watched this movie with
my kids
and i was like holy
you can't watch this with your kids i
forgot how much cursing is in it
i was like
and i was like but yeah i was like ah i
just tried to be louder than like what
was happening but i didn't realize like
what i was watching when i was a kid but
watching you right now like you watch
the goonies you talking about the
goonies is as entertaining for me as you
watching the games i was such a fan of
them and it was who's your favorite
character i'm sorry to interrupt but
who's your favorite character this is
going to get controversial but we were
going to get married so that's that's
why so
no
this is our picture
[Music]
you